I just gave a guest lecture last week at
University of Texas for a class on
entrepreneurship there are some people
here who don't try for one of the
key questions that many of the aspiring
entrepreneurs in the classroom asked is
what should I sell first off we have to
Define what are the actual things that
can be sold and this may sound crazy but
there's actually fewer of them than you
think and there's digital and physical
formats of each of these things which
actually give you 14 different things
you can possibly sell once I Define
those I'll talk about how we can
increase the scale of the deliverable
that we have using something that I call
the delivery Cube number one is you can
sell products you could sell a physical
product which would be like I sell water
bottles a digital product would be
something like a PDF the second category
is services so this is stuff you do for
other people in the Physical Realm a
service would be a massage mowing
someone's lawn fixing someone's car on
the digital side oftentimes that service
is something that happens in the digital
space so if you are an ad agency and you
make ads the ad itself that you're
making as a service also buying media is
a service all of those things would be
Digital Services category three you have
access Visual access is like you lease a
building you gain access to the building
digital access is you gain access to a
library of digital content like Netflix
category 4 is attention you can sell or
buy physical attention that could be
like a billboard cars physically drive
past it and see it to the same degree
Facebook and Google have digital
attention and they sell the eyeballs and
the attention of that audience Category
5 like the hurricane is risk selling
insurance but you can insure a building
but you can also insure against in the
digital format a cyber threat if you're
an established business owner and you
sell physical products or even Services
you can sell the risk associated with it
which is like ensuring the product so
some people give guarantees but you can
actually get people to pay for a
guarantee which is Insurance just like
AppleCare is just paid for insurance the
next thing you can buy or sell is money
itself the entire banking industry is
predicated on buying and selling money
and the rate they charge is the interest
itself and so you can have physical
money right like the actual US Dollars
you can also have digital money which
I'm not going to get into crypto but
that is a form of digital money category
seven is an endorsement or brand in the
physical world I say hey you can use my
logo on your shirt and you give me a
percentage of all your sales in the
Digital World when they sell a check
mark on Instagram that is selling an
endorsement it's selling a brand it's
selling some sort of status that gets
transferred and a fee is paid as a
result of that one of the key points
here is that it can be a combination of
those categories so if someone sells a
rock concert for example you're selling
access to an experience but you might
also sell drinks and t-shirts while
you're there now you might record it and
then also sell the digital versions that
see what I'm going with here in terms of
picking which one to sell it's mostly
going to come down to two things one is
the resources you have and your skills
value experience if you're a first-time
entrepreneur then you're like well I
don't have any other experience but you
actually do and let me hear me out your
parents did something and if you don't
have parents the people who praise you
did something and if no one raised you
people you knew did something and you
were around them so like for example my
mom is a doctor she's an eye surgeon so
I know a lot of stuff about eyes that
would be a category of stuff that I
actually know a lot more about than you
might expect if your dad was a mechanic
you probably know what a carburetor is I
have no idea what it is I've heard the
word before oftentimes you've had little
odd jobs like when I was in high school
I was a blender tenor and then I did
catering at an Orthodox Jewish company
you probably know a lot of stuff just
from osmosis of being around it we have
these seven things digital and physical
is there any one of these that already
have a little bit more experience with
and then of those things which problem
is the biggest that I think I can solve
given the resources that I have access
to what I was talking about with this
entrepreneurship group is that they had
a hundred dollars to start their
business now that would probably
preclude you from most physical products
probably most kind of digital like
software type stuff and so most of the
time you're going to start selling your
time which is often Services here's the
person I provide the most value to for
the least I'm amount of money to me
that's where your sweet spot is as the
first or next thing that I would
probably package and sell once you've
established that how can I enhance or
make it more or less valuable or more or
less profitable for me as a business
owner the delivery Cube has six pieces
to it that's eight six number one is can
I deliver this thing one to one in a
small group can I deliver it one to many
each of these have different value
propositions that are associated with
them if you sold semi-private group
stuff it's a small group of five people
doing something that's different than
doing a webinar to a thousand people at
once versus having a call review system
where you review someone's calls to give
them feedback one-on-one the second
frame of the delivery cube is do it
yourself DIY DWI which is done with you
as in you're holding their hand through
the process of whatever it is you're
doing or done for you where you do all
of the work yourself and you sell them a
final product or final outcome each of
these give you different levels of scale
do it yourself you can sell it unlimited
out typically the value is smaller done
with you you have in between mean the
two extremes of do-it-yourself and done
four you've done for you is the most
expensive typically sometimes the
easiest to sell but one of the hardest
things to deliver on the third frame is
what level of support am I going to do
and specifically on what medium am I
going to offer support via chat am I
going to offer support via email am I
going to offer support via phone call
gonna be Zoom call these are all
different ways that I can support
whatever the thing is that I'm selling
obviously if I do email support that's
going to be significantly more scalable
it'll probably also be significantly
less valuable than somebody who's real
time available to hop on a zoom call
whenever they want filter number four is
how do I want them to consume the thing
they can consume it visually they
consume It audio wise they could consume
it live they consume a recording they
consume it visually via text so there's
different ways we can have people
consume some sort of thing whatever it
is anything that's live is typically
going to be perceived as more valuable
and if it's in person and live probably
the most valuable and probably the least
scalable on the flip side if I did
something that was recorded and was
digital it would be the most scalable
but probably the least valuable the
fifth lens is the speed and convenience
of whatever we're delivering this comes
down to multiple things one is it 24
hours a day or is it just nine to five
frame two is how many days a week am I
maintaining that level of service three
is how fast is that response so I might
be open 24 hours a day but I have
responses that are guaranteed in 24
hours which is different than saying I'm
open nine to five five days a week but I
respond within three minutes and the
ultimate extremes are either you're
overstaffed but your customers don't
have to wait you incur inefficiency so
that they have convenience or they incur
the inefficiency and all of your staff
is 100 utilized because they're going
call to call to call all day long
different strategies there's wildly
successful companies that do both frame
six is what I like to call the 10x to 1
10th test if I charge 10 times more for
my current thing what would I have to
change about my thing that I sell in
order for it to be worth 10 times more
this ultimately gets me thinking in much
bigger ways about how much value I would
need to provide let's say I go from a
ten thousand dollar thing to a hundred
thousand dollar thing that still would
be profitable at a ten thousand dollar
thing it just makes me think differently
because I now have to justify my hundred
thousand dollar price tag the flip side
of that is equally powerful which is if
I had to deliver the same or even more
value than I currently am but I could
only charge one tenth the price that I
currently am what else would I do that
would be perceived as valuable but would
not cost me enough so I could still
justify one tenth the price but maintain
my value this gives me a very good
starting point to both figure out what
the first thing I might want to sell is
and then how can I scale it and make it
more profitable and or more valuable to
my end consumer and think through the
ratio of how many people I would need
internally my company to facilitate that
and so this is what I was explaining
with the University of Texas and if this
was interesting to you we actually have
the entire full lecture in Q a the link
somewhere around here I'm sure it'll be
available to you if you want to watch
the whole thing go click there and check
it out